Liebe Männer, wenn ihr wissen wollt wir frauen auf jeden Fall
Herum kriegt habe ich jetzt die Antwort für euch lasst, die Musik hören ein Experiment aus Wien zeigt nämlich jetzt
Dass frauen Männer sehr viel Attraktiver finden
Wenn sie Musik hören und zwar die richtige wie genau Musik die sexuelle Anziehung beeinflusst
Welche Musik ihr beim Dayton unbedingt spielen müsst und ob das gleiche auch für Frauen gilt jetzt in Klicks um Science-Fiction herzlich willkommen
Man müsste Klavier spielen können
Ja an diesen Uralten Lied von Johannes Heesters scheint sogar wissenschaftlich etwas dran zu sein in der Forschung
Unumstritten ist die Wirkung die Musik auf uns hat schon Embryos im Bauch der Mutter
Reagieren auf Musik sie steckt einfach Tief in unserer Natur darin übrigens hat sich schon charles Darwin mit der Wirkung der Musik
auseinandergesetzt
Seiner Meinung nach hat sie sich überhaupt erst durch die sexuelle Selektion
Entwickelt demnach hatten diejenigen Personen den größten Fort Fand Forschungserfolg
Die die Fähigkeit besaßen Musik zu machen denn das galt seiner Meinung nach als Indikator für Gute Gene fest steht jedenfalls
Musik ist sehr eng mit der menschlichen Gefühlswelt
Verknüpft und nicht nur das frühere Studien haben gezeigt, dass Musik nicht nur unseren geist berührt
Sondern auch unseren Körper, wir nehmen Berührung tatsächlich anders war
Wenn wir während dessen Musik hören und nicht nur das auch die Aktivität unserer gene verändert sich ein
Experiment aus Wien zeigt jetzt
Dass Musik auch bei der Partnerwahl eine enorm große Rolle spielen kann
Zitat die Attraktivität des Gesichts ist eines der wichtigsten körperlichen Merkmale welches die Partnerwahl beeinflussen
Kann wir wollten herausfinden?
Wie musik die Wahrnehmung dieses merkmals womöglich verändert sagt der beteiligte Psychologe Helmut Leder insgesamt?
690 versuchs Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer waren am Experiment der Uni Wien beteiligt den ausschließlich
Heterosexuellen Probanden wurden Musik Ausschnitte vorgespielt und links rein, Instrumentale Musik aus dem 19
Jahrhundert so etwas wie Brahms Chopin oder schubert?
Danach wurden in Fotos von Menschen mit den Jeweils anderen geschlecht gezeigt die Leute auf den Bildern zeigten einen neutralen Gesichtsausdruck
Die Aufgabe Bestand darin die Menschen auf den Fotos hinsichtlich ihrer Attraktivität zu beurteilen zudem
Sollten sie sagen?
Ob sie einem Date Zustimmen würden die Kontrollgruppe sei auch gesichter allerdings ohne Musik und das Ergebnis ist wirklich mehr als
Überraschend die Frauen ließen sich in ihrer Beurteilung total von der Musik beeinflussen
Wenn sie zuvor Musik gehört hatten fanden sie die Gesichter der Männer deutlich
Attraktiver zudem waren sie deutlich öfter bereit ein Date mit diesen Männern zu haben liebe Männer Hiermit
Also der offizielle Tipp von Seiten der Wissenschaft organisiert euch für eure Days Music
Das erhöht eure Chancen enorm wichtig dazu noch zu wissen auch die Art der Musik spielt eine große Rolle
das Experiment aus Wien zeigt, dass frauen sich sexuell umso mehr von Männern angezogen fühlen je komplexer und
erregender die Zuvor gehörte
Musik war so die Studie die Männer dagegen waren total unbeeindruckt von der Musik sie zeigten sich völlig Immun gegen die Wirkung der Musik
der Plan des Forschungsteams ist jetzt herauszufinden Inwieweit das musikalische Talent eine rolle bei der Partnerwahl spielt hat ein
Herausragender Musiker der mittelmäßig aussieht eventuell mehr Chancen bei den Frauen als ein völlig
Unmusikalische man mit dem Aussehen eines Models
Also nach dem Motto man müsste Klavier spielen können ja hier bei Pixum erfahrt ihr natürlich, wenn es halt so neue Erkenntnisse gibt
wenn er kein Video zum Thema und auch zu allen anderen Themen verpassen wollt, dann würden wir hier ein Abo aufsaugen vergessen ich den
Auf die Glocke hier geht es weiter mit bedroht künstliche Intelligenz die Menschheit
Da geht es um den Sieg von Alpha go spannendes Video natürlich also nicht verpassen und draufklicken. Viel Spaß dabei und ansonsten. Bis dann
Bleibt dran